so wonderful to see you all three uh
Helen last time I saw you was in Vegas
from 1923 and you just happened to pick
action movie after action movie
Adventures rolls you do your own stunts
you break your finger I think we can
officially call you an adrenaline rush
junkie good yeah
you know I do all the stuff in between
but you know and these kind of movies is
such fun and when you're working with
you know women like these
um it's just pure fun really except for
the the struggle of wearing incredibly
heavy costumes in 80 degrees weather and
uh you know high humidity but apart from
that that was nothing your lines to me
on after the first day of shooting you
whispered in my ear to remember what did
you say she said they're trying to kill
us
it's incredible fun to do this you know
movies like this
it's beautiful and Lucy I mean I think
everyone's going to react the way I
think I'm sure a lot of people have
talked to you about it but the fact we
think about Charlie's Angel and that
Dynamic and the three of you as the
daughters of Atlas do you see
similarities or do you think everyone's
just completely off
I don't know I don't think it's the same
I think playing friends
um as opposed to being sisters is so
different you know there's a sister that
develops when you're friends working
together but I think as sisters there's
a rivalry and there's a dynamic that's
so different there's a hierarchy there's
uh acquiescing there's sides so there's
a there's a you know there's something
in play there that is just
um you can get away with it a little bit
you know like if you're if you're if
you're friends and and somebody sort of
takes one side it can come off as a
little bit but in this case it's just a
given so it's quite different what's fun
about it is that we are sisters on and
off camera and that Dynamic development
naturally and it was just a beautiful
thing I mean if we didn't have to do the
interviews we'd just be sitting here
talking about
absolutely would you ever want yeah
that's the other great thing but you
know it
um a chemistry is a is a very
interesting thing isn't it yeah and we
just immediately found the chemistry
together of the three of us and I think
it's not least because you don't often
get the chance to work with two fellow
actors female actors yeah you know in in
that very close and continue all the way
through a movie you might have a scene
with another actress or but um well I
guess like you and Charlie's Angels but
you know that that Continuum
was great
yeah and Rachel I don't I'm just in all
of you we're just so proud of you from
West Side Story to this and look at the
ladies you're sitting next to I mean
have you kind of sat back and reflected
how cool this really is I keep winning
the lottery I really do I really do it
was a thing I was going through my
photos the other day and I have there
was a a and you know your phone kind of
makes a note for you sometimes and it
was just called on camera and it was a
picture of me being directed by Steven
Spielberg and then right after is a
picture of like Helen holding my face on
set and I was like what is my life does
it make any sense but I am so naturally
it's not a lottery because it's not luck
it's not luck it's not you know of
course we all we are of course part of
our job now profession is like of course
a part of it is but a huge amount of it
in your case I would say he's pure
unadulterated Talent you know
extraordinary Talent so like
I just want to hang out
and hang out I love the love between you
guys congratulations on this film and
love you guys take care thank you thanks
everyone how are you guys doing wow is
that yours wow
[Laughter]
thank you thank you that means a lot to
me and I have to say I can't believe you
guys are in a film with a dragon
mythical creatures a unicorn there's so
many Easter eggs in this film it's
ridiculous what surprised you the most
about this film there must be a
particular moment you're just like whoa
did that just happen yeah they did a
weird thing when we when they made the
dragon
um sculpture they used real Ivory which
I thought was like whoa that's kind of
out of date no way kid I'm kidding
that's a messed up thing I shouldn't
have said no what I didn't expect so
when we were filming this I um
uh we there was like I I'm now watching
them after watching the movie I'm
realizing like oh my God all of these
like tennis balls we were supposed to be
scared of are have become dragons and
like these cardboard cutouts are
manticores and and uh and hippogriffs or
or uh what are they called minotaurs
minotaurs and it's just like it's it's
amazing to see that movie Magic is very
much alive in this film yeah you know if
you did have the power of Shazam and I
know you're getting this question a lot
but if you could transfer yourself into
someone else beside your adult self who
would you want to be
refined
that's a good one is that yours wait
what
I'm into anybody if I can beat anybody
but myself yeah
um if you can say Shazam and then you
turn into somebody else that's so hard
uh uh uh I'm gonna say Matt Damon I was
gonna say Maddie Matheson you know who
he is no he's a he's a chef slash hockey
player cool great
Steve Jobs
oh that's a good one
that's a really good one I like that and
you know you could have said Helen
Mirren I mean you guys are in the film
Dame Helen Mirren like oh I didn't know
that was an option
but we didn't want it like you know I
don't know we weren't really cool I
didn't want to step on any toes yeah
she'd probably be upset about that yeah
okay dude let me tell me how it was
meeting her for the first time because
this is Helen Mirren like she's she's
Queen it was kind of actually uh well
you know something I met her the first
time in Las Vegas we had a wild night
um but actually I took a picture with
her and and I like met her and I didn't
know that she was going to be in Shazam
too this was afraid Shazam one I'm sure
I was there for a different thing and
then I reminded her of it and she said
oh my god of course I remember you and
then she said oh my God that and she
said that she really she was like going
to the strip club that night was crazy
and I was like oh my God her humor is
great and we're like doing a bit right
now we're like doing a bit I'm doing a
bit with Helen Mirren this is awesome
and we were we laughed and it was like a
sigh of relief like oh my God this is
this is the heat is off she's so cool
right cool she's so cool I love her yeah
I mean this time I met Helen was at
Cinema con
um no way after we were filming I didn't
even get to meet her um so I mean she I
know she's so elegant and amazing and
you know Jack could say this Jack and I
can both say the same thing I think we
can both agree on this you know we've
looked up to her entire career and she
has such profound work and she's such a
great human truly so it's been so cool
learning from her you guys are amazing
congratulations on this film I wish I
could talk to you guys more but you love
your energy keep going guys you guys are
just so proud of you we love you guys
vampire the gods come on any secondary
Canada come on over